And you might not be
a real judge,
but based on your robe
and your pigmentation,
I would swear that you were.
I've got all the tools,
right?
Yes, you got all the tools.
I'm [bleep] robed and white.
I'm ready to go.
You look like a guy that
gave me seven years before.
No!
Yes, you do.
Oh, I apologize for that
on behalf of all of us.
What'd you get
seven years for?
Oh, I was a stick-up kid.
I was a stick-up kid.
Just a young,
misguided individual
who really needed a chance
coming up in the inner city
lacking a father figure.
I've seen that movie
a bunch of times.
[Bleep]
Why doesn't that movie
fix the problem?
They keep making it, and yet
the situation keeps occurring.
I don't know.
You know what I was
thinking in there?
I was thinking they should
bring back corded phones.
'Cause then these things
won't -- these incidents
will stop happening
with the people
getting phones
thrown at them.
'Cause if the phone's
got a cord on it, you know,
it'll just snap back
right away.
You know what? That actually
can work a few ways because,
like, in the event
that you throw your phone
to hit somebody in the head
and then, you know,
you can't retrieve your phone,
it's nice to be able
to retrieve --
You get it back again.
You get your phone back.
Yeah.
Kind of like a bungee phone.
But you got to be
kinda like a ninja.
You got to be a master at it,
'cause if you throw it wrong,
it come back and pop you
right in the mouth or something.
So, you know,
sometimes karma might happen.
That would be
embarrassing.
But karma may need
to intervene sometimes.
Hey, Judge,
tell the receptionist lady
don't grind the weed up
that small no more
when they know I'm coming.
That got too ground up?
It got too ground up, 'cause
you know I smoke them blunts,
you got to have
some chunky buds in there.
But I understand
you like the balls.
Oh, you like to have some
chunky buds in there.
Yeah, I do.
All right.
Chunky style.
Chunky.
It really "shunky."
It got to say "shunky."
You like "shunks"
in your Reese's
and things like that
and your Snickers?
I guess Snickers always
has "shunks" in it.
I don't want no "shunks"
in my Reese's, those.
It's supposed to be smooth,
creamy peanut butter.
Okay.
Where do you like
your "shunks," then?
Just in a blunt?
I like my "shunky" buds
and "shunky" bank accounts.
[ Laughs ] Okay.